[Applaudissements]
merci adrien et adrien est beau gosse
député beau gosse a franchement merci
adrien d'être là merci à vous je sais
rien sur twitter il va avoir un
déferlement il est beau gosse il est
beau gosse il est beau gosse il est
surtout là pour nous parler du handicap
adrien alors adrien merci déjà déplacé
c'est courageux de bord votre part il
paraît que vous avez été missionné par
le premier ministre pour travailler sur
le handicap c'est pas courageux d'être
là vous vous l'évoquiez tout à l'heure
je crois j'ai effectivement été à
l'origine du mouvement marché est calme
à croire que j'ai compris à ses côtés
c'est qu'il fallait aller au contact
aller là où sont les gens qui sont là et
dans une grande émission populaire comme
la vôtre américain ils sont regardés qui
regarde et je crois par beaucoup de
jeunes
oui je pense que c'est important de
venir parler de ces sujets là et c'est
votre question vous disais marion tout à
l'heure si effectivement vous remercier
et même vous féliciter parce que je
crois que c'est sincère d'organiser ce
genre de démission est formidable c'est
que vous avez effectivement des
chroniqueurs seront tous sens et toutes
et tous en situation de handicap mais
qu'on ne parle pas de handicap non et on
va parler de la présence des personnes
en situation de handicap dans les médias
mais on aura gagné
effectivement il y aura des personnes en
situation de handicap dans les médias
pour parler d'autre chose que du
handicap et c'est ce qu'on est en train
de faire ce soir
merci et bravo pour sa mère fleuriste
l'or
moi je veux dire la vérité quand on va
voir des patrons de chaînes quand on va
voir
mine de rien des producteurs tout le
monde vous dis moi un mec handicapés à
l'antenne ça va pas faire d'audience
parce qu'on dit les choses ici donc les
mecs king disent nous on est une
entreprise mine de rien on doit faire
rentrer des sous et donc on peut pas le
faire on peut pas mettre des mecs comme
ça à l'antenne tu vas voir ça va pas
marcher
vous êtes donc il ya il ya d'abord un
aspect économique pourquoi est ce que
vous trouvez vous autour de la table qui
a assez de personnes en situation de
handicap à la télévision alors handicap
et des personnes handicapées à la télé
il y en a très peu hein
vous en connaissez vous mais moi j'ai
une chronique sur france 5 depuis 59 ans
il ya frédéric zeitoun choujaïya et
zeitoun où il ya des personnes qui est
son gré le risque à la radio web
beaucoup à la radio signal à
quelques-uns il ya un garçon sur m6
grégory cuilleron et qui étaient pourvus
de l'avant bras gauche également qu'on a
vu il ya ashley qu'on a vu dans la
nouvelle star sur m6 également une
candidate non voyantes et malvoyantes et
surtout des candidats
1 si je peux me permettre un garçon un
formidable qui est autiste asperger qui
s'appelle jozef chovanec et qui a des
chroniques sur europe1 suffit pas de
bêtises s'appelle voyage en autiste ans
c'est formidable je vous conseille
d'écouter de le lire aussi parce qu'il
en a fait est fait et ça marche très
bien pour lui de ne pas vous dire que ça
marche et ça peut ça peut marcher julien
est ce que vous trouvez qu'on a c'est
alors c'est pas qui est je trouve
qu'elle a assez ou pas assez c'est qu'il
faut pas oublier aussi une chose 80% des
handicapés c'est invisible
la plupart d'entre eux ils n'ont pas
trop envie de le dire comme on a vu
leurs parts à tout à l'heure actuelle
avec marc soto exactement il n'avait pas
forcément envie de le dire
et il y en a beaucoup encore
malheureusement qui n'ont pas encore le
l'envi de le dire deuxième point c'est
qu'en fait on a aussi des radios qui
sont spécialisés avec des chroniqueurs
des journalistes en situation de
handicap par exemple je pense avec
vincent locmane de la radio vivre fm ou
en fait là ce sont que des handicapés
qui travaillent derrière mais nous ce
corps et même dérange
est-ce qu'on est moins intéressant parce
que j'y vais avec adrien avec monsieur
taquet il ya un instant c'est que nous
moi ça m'intéresse pas qui ni que des
handicapés
l'émission est bien parti
de la diversité la diversité quelle que
soit la différence que ce soit une
couleur de peau que ce soit une religion
une croyance une différence physique
quelle qu'elle soit il faut accepter la
différence à part de radio excuse moi
mais pas de radio de handicap mais qui
écoute une radio sur le handicap la
personne handicapée débat non j'ai pas
envie d'écouter ça c'est bon ça c'est
moi handicap ce même goût ça me va je
vous dis alors que le valider du manant
ça m'intéresse pas philippe il ya un
truc qui est dit par les patrons de
chaînes vous sûrs tirez qui souvent les
handicapés ne veulent pas voir des
handicapés à l'antenne et j'en ai pas
papa un groupe à un groupe d'handicapés
ça que l'essec important regarde
franchement s'il ya bien un groupe qu'il
fait c'est france télévision il vaquait
vraiment met le paquet avec le programme
court bestiaire les jeux paralympiques à
trois rivières est candidate
le sadisme et c'est extraordinaire on
est dans un début de changement se
disant plus un truc c'est que ça
cartonne en audience depuis sa carte a
cartonné c'est extraordinaire je dirais
pas que le changement c'est maintenant
ce que ça va fonctionner par les cheveux
on est vraiment celui là avec adrien pas
que les situations
la situation aujourd'hui c'est les
personnes en situation de handicap à la
télé c'est 0 8%
vous avez vous avez 12 millions de
personnes en france ces serres en
situation de handicap
il vous avez 0 8% de représentation a
été encore 0,8 pour mille pour cent
parce qu'il y avait eu des jeux
olympiques annonce et 0,4 donc c'est un
vrai sujet juste moi je vous je vous
renvoie une question on va pas beaucoup
de personnes handicapées dans les médias
moi je me pose la question pourquoi on
va pas beaucoup de personnes handicapées
dans les écoles
[Applaudissements]
dans les entreprises pas beaucoup de
personnes handicapées non mais c'est
vrai que s'ils voulaient le sujet en
fait et dia le sujet il est global saint
pal de société on est parent pour plein
de raisons légales noter si vous voulez
on n'est pas dans une société
aujourd'hui inclusive et voilà les
personnes en situation de handicap sont
des personnes comme les autres qui
vivent aujourd'hui pour améliorer les
choses c'est que c'est vraiment un des
chevaux de bataille du président de la
république est ce que il ya des choses
qui se sont déjà amélioré même pour
aussi les handicapés au quotidien parce
que moi je sais qu'un handicapé il tout
le monde pourra tous mes potes en niqab
et me disent tu vois un truc que tu fais
en 12 secondes
moi je le fais en deux heures donc c'est
donc c'est un de cheval de bataille voir
un des chevaux de bataille effectivement
du lodévois ont bien des raisons de la
république vient dé cheval de bataille
le sien à l'échelle de bataille
attention je parle très bien français
c'est très important ce que vous évoquez
effectivement une des premières choses à
faire ça peut paraître anecdotique ça
peut permettre à paraître un peu
technique mais je sais que toutes les
personnes autour de la table savent à
quel point c'est important et c'est ce
que vous venez d'évoquer la question des
démarches administratives
c'est derek petit mais très content au
journal un système d' allahou akbar on a
empilé les systèmes je voulais quelque
chose par rapport à l'intégration
j'ai parlé de l'inclusion écoles et tout
le reste on y un peu aujourd'hui on n'y
est pas encore totalement mais un peu
d'intégration dans les écoles mais comme
disait cyril dans les médias dans le
milieu de la mode notamment parce que je
fais partie d'une association n'a pas
beaucoup mais pas seulement 10 et en a
pas il n'y a pas d'ingérence de
mannequinat en france
je savais alors qu'il en a deux
oui oui julia pour revenir au débat ont
parlé quand même de la place des
handicapés dans les dents les moyens
faut pas oublier aussi une chose c'est
que avant en 2005 dans les entreprises
on avait cette même difficulté de faire
l'inclusion des entre des personnes
handicapées au travail on a mis en place
par les gouvernements précédents et
c'était jacques chirac à l'époque il a
mis en place ce qu'on appelle des quotas
ouais est ce qu'aujourd'hui la solution
n'est pas là pour qu'il y ait des
handicapés dans les médias dans les
films dans les séries etc
ce serait de mettre en place tout à zéro
le collectif parce que les quotas c'est
un peu de son hôte s'agit il ya des
dispositifs pour le dans l'homme sur le
marché de l'emploi on voit que ça ne
fonctionne pas très bien ce terreau
pirée là aussi c'est culturel alors ça
va être compliqué parce que c'est ce qui
est le plus dur à changer mais
aujourd'hui effectivement mais la raison
une contre un dans une entreprise à
avoir des personnes en situation de
handicap c'est perçu comme une
contrainte comme un coup voir comment
apprêter attendus tout à l'heure j'ai
entendu un gérant jérôme et si on
parlait de performante
voilà moi je pense que pôle business
faut juste employer les termes du
business dire qu'il faut faire
comprendre aux chefs d'entreprises dont
je viens moi j'étais j'étais chef
d'entreprise d'être député mais aussi
aux autres salariés
parce que parfois les autres salariés
ont des craintes aussi fait ça va leur
faire comprendre qu'en fait personnes en
situation de handicap
en fait ça peut être un levier de
performance vous parle pour l'entreprise
je suis là même choisir une source de
bien-être suis d'accord mais leurs
espoirs dans l'image on est encore dans
l'image
handicapé galko des thénardier ouais
crois qu'on ne sera pas sorti de cette
[ __ ] d'image laisse qu'une moitié un
gros mot mais là c'est vraiment toi tu
apportes c'est une image qui nous colle
à la peau handicapé galles jeune
handicapé gall s'était pas quoi en faire
l'handicapé peur dont le shifter j'y
vais pas je sais pas comment affronter
la personne donc qu'il soit forcé la
main de jean les chirinos confiant wouah
voilà je vous dis la vérité
moi j'ai une entreprise et j'ai très peu
de personnes handicapées qui viennent
pour voir des postes chez moi quoi s'il
fascisation bas parce que parce qu'il ya
une peur j'en suis certain de me dire
bah non mais pourquoi ils viennent pas
comprendre et apprendre et même et j'en
ai pas
il a d'adrien gt c'est intéressant ce
que vous évoquez parce que cet appel
c'est la semaine ne se bougent peu aussi
européennes d'emploi pour les personnes
il fallait donc j'ai toute cette semaine
j'ai été visité des entreprises voilà
pour rencontrer les valoriser cet
après-midi jeter dans une grande
entreprise publique en l'occurrence rte
lance comme ils ont une politique assez
plutôt plutôt exemplaire en la matière
bon effectivement la fin de drh m'a dit
moi j'ai un problème de sourcing en fait
j'ai pas assez de c donc je pense qu'il
ya un problème aussi à brême aussi
l'adéquation sur les formations etc star
donc ça le demander ce qu'on va faire
quatre fois par exemple là dessus alors
la lazio par exemple on commence à
initier globalement au delà du handicap
le chantier de la formation
professionnelle de l'apprentissage
externe et la négociation qui s'ouvre
entre le gouvernement et le et les
syndicats dès le départ
sophie cluzel à la secrétariat se
prêtèrent d'étape avant chargé des
personnes handicapées muriel pénicaud
la ministre du travail on dit dans ces
négociations la ja il faut mettre la
question du handicap
parmi les les discussions c'est un peu
aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que fait le gouvernement
qu'est ce qui change c'est ce que
j'appelle vont aux appels baba mon
m'appelle coucou à l'assemblée parce que
j'adopte la stratégie du coucou moi
c'est quoi ce quel que soit le sujet
quel que soit le sujet on se dit on
pense personnes handicapées qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire spécifique pour changer
la situation pour changer la culture
alors je voudrais la vie de malick sy 2
secondes non moi justement je pense que
quand tu disais quand on le contourne
excuses et maurice question il ya dedans
mais quand on disait tout à l'heure que
justement ce que disait à julien 80% des
handicapés est invisible
voilà c'est invisible et aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il ya un problème d'affirmation
d'une part on devrait tous se
reconnaître ceux qui sont déjà à la télé
en poste dans la politique et ça devrait
le dire assez facilement il adore il
devrait y avoir de gêne la danse et les
compétences qu'on juge
on a chacun nos compétences et c'est ça
qu'on devrait mettre en avant ce que
disait ce que disait oui messieurs tel
un gain l'instant c'est qu'il faut que
les mecs comprennent et moi et moi je
suis le premier je dois le combat aussi
c'est que les personnes handicapées
elles sont aussi performante si ce n'est
plus voilà je voulais voilà c'est faute
voilà c'est ça qu'il faut pas juste un
truc qui nous gêne c'est un mot le mot
handicap c'est ça quand je mets une
conférence en entreprise que je parais
de dépassement de soi des objectifs à
atteindre le travail d'équipé je fait
carton plein cette semaine je suis je me
suis pas les noms
une entreprise il ya le mot handicap il
ya cinquante personnes dans la salle
chier ce mot j'ai fait jouer aujourd'hui
j'ai vu une grosse société à la défense
à quatre mille personnes dans la tour il
y avait 50 personnages la conférence
s'ouvre il a prêché je parle du problème
si on marche marquait une solution c'est
un truc carla es-tu nous dit aux soldats
chronique ah ben non moi juste que je
voulais dire moi personnellement je
sache et l'euphrate à feu doux tout cas
pas loin de 20 ans et plusieurs fois je
suis allé dans les écoles primaires pour
masquer leur en veux pas
aujourd'hui ça va faire trois ans puis à
l'université il ya aucune loi aucun truc
qui est fait pour m'aider moi à la fête
pour des histoires les études et ça fait
comment après je peux réussir si l'écran
la salsa et admire quelqu'un quoi
l'avoir métier et me voir qu'il parte
dans un état où la tempête graphie mais
réussir dans la vie
après gta il faut qu'on peut apporter
une solution
directement concerné j'étais viré
d'administration je suis revenue j'ai
fait un peu le yoyo pour à cause d'eux à
cause de mon handicap
par contre maintenant à l'heure actuelle
bon c'était il ya sept huit ans
maintenant je suis je suis super bien où
je suis par contre ils recrutent
vraiment à fond sur tout ce qui est post
administratifs etc mais de l'état en
fait les ministères de l'intérieur et
c'est donc allez-y si vous avez vraiment
besoin à ces résolutions
yann c'était il ya deux choses il ya
énormément d'enfants à qui on rejette
l'accès à l'école et lâche ma part oui
c'est vrai que je connais l'importance
mais je pense que malheureusement il
n'ya pas que les enfants autistes
ensuite les une chose c'est le coup des
prises en charge l'état dépense
énormément d'argent pour s'acheter une
prise en charge de mauvaise qualité qui
amène pas les enfants ça à devenir plus
tard des adultes indépendant et autonome
et à côté il ya des outils qui coûte pas
forcément très cher qui de toute façon
coûte moins cher que ce qui est fait à
l'heure actuelle et qui permettrait
l'accès à l'école d'enfants et on refuse
des enfants qui vont à l'école en
belgique aujourd'hui on veut et ça ça
y'a pas de seuil et par la sécurité
sociale française
est-ce que ça va bouger en fait on
reconnaît qu'il ya c'est la dernière qui
se joue peut déjà dans les médias est ce
qu'on va avoir plus de personnes
handicapées ou pas du tout bien ça c'est
pas ou feint je crois pas que ce soit
législature le dire une entreprise de
médias c'est une entreprise comme elle à
une ruelle à moi je pense qu'elle a une
responsabilité sociale par ailleurs et
je pense que le service public a
probablement une responsabilité sociale
un peu plus grande que les autres alors
mais effectivement ça va bouger par les
initiatives que vous prenez directives
de vos petits camarades de tf1 avec la
mention particulière
voilà c'est ça qu'il faut faire c'est
comme ça et puis faut que toute la
société bouge on aille vers une société
inclusive et c'est comme ça que ça va ça
va changer
ben pour conclure voilà toutes les
chaînes de télévision autour de la table
vous avez plein de petits harry
roselmack a envie d'y aller exactement
mamers
voilà mercier a pris l'attaqué référent